[Música]
en directo América de France 24 más
Romero salas con nosotros en el estudio
mar bienvenida nuevamente vamos a seguir
hablando de el VIH y el sida en el Día
Mundial de la lucha contra estas
enfermedades ahora para retroceder en el
tiempo mar Por qué Porque Cuáles son los
orígenes de este virus y también de la
enfermedad no para dar un poco más de
contexto claro tenemos que ir hacia
atrás para entender lo que está
sucediendo hoy en día eso como siempre
no el virus se prevé se calcula que
saltó de los chimpancés a los humanos
alrededor de 1920 en los años 20
probablemente fue en Camerún pero no fue
hasta que llegó a quinchasa la capital
de República democrática del Congo que
ahí empezó a expandirse Por qué pues era
una Tormenta perfecta un poco que
hincharse en ese momento era una de las
ciudades que más rápido crecía en la
región que más estaba desarrollando Y
eso ayudó a que se fuera expandiendo por
toda la región de África por ejemplo
subsahariana no Y además lo hizo de
forma relativamente silenciosa por
varios factores primero por el tiempo
que pasa entre la infección del VIH y
que se empiecen a desarrollar los
síntomas de la enfermedad el hecho
también de que el VIH ataque al sistema
inmune Entonces estos síntomas se
manifiestan como normalmente otras
enfermedades otras infecciones
que aparecen y que no son necesariamente
nuevas no entonces están bien hacía que
fuera menos visto y también por último
obviamente porque estaba sucediendo en
una zona que no estaba tan investigada
que no se estaba que no tenía tantas
herramientas para el control de las
enfermedades no así poco a poco se fue
expandiendo por el mundo y se calcula
que por ejemplo a Estados Unidos que es
donde empezó donde se dio el primer
grito de alarma llegó a través de Haití
probablemente en 1969 así Esa fue la
fecha que se ha dado después de estudios
genómicos ahí fue que se pues se
identificó el problema se vio que estaba
afectando a hombres sobre todo que
tenían sexo con hombres hombres gay
hombres bisexuales y no fue hasta 1983
que se aisló el virus se identificó y se
vio que este era el virus que estaba
causando la enfermedad y ahí también
empieza la historia de la discriminación
Lamentablemente totalmente en los 80 en
Estados Unidos hoy vivir con VIH tienes
la oportunidad al menos de que se viva
como una enfermedad Crónica pero en su
origen era una sentencia de muerte para
todos los que recibían el diagnóstico de
nuevo especialmente hombres gay o
hombres bisexuales Y tenemos algunos
ejemplos de eso que son los nombres que
recibía el sida al inicio no primero se
le empezó a llamar grip que era gay
relateds deficiencia inmune relacionada
con los gays pero es que incluso llegó a
apodarse la enfermedad de las cuatro H
por las comunidades de las que afectaba
homosexuales hemofílicos heroinómenos y
haitianos no exacto no como unos Además
nos da muchas pistas sobre los factores
sociales y de transmisión que estaban
afectando a estas comunidades
precisamente unas comunidades que nadie
quería mirar y por eso fue que tardó
tanto en desarrollarse algo de lucha
contra el sida por ejemplo en Estados
Unidos Ronald Reagan que era el
presidente tardó cinco años entre que se
detectó Primero este virus y pues que él
pronunció la palabra sida eight es decir
paso todo ese tiempo también en la lucha
no que empezó a darse fondos no la
primera lucha que hubo contra el sida
fue con uñas y dientes de la comunidad
lgbti de los hombres pero también de las
mujeres y todas esas pues personas que
acompañaron a estas personas en esas
primeras luchas cuando ya había miles y
miles de muertos en Estados Unidos muy
dura la situación con los enfermos en
esa época y un estigma que también dura
hasta el día de hoy mar claro no Aunque
el conocimiento sobre el VIH aumentado
muchísimo y hay mucho más
sensibilización también hay muchas más
oportunidades no no quiere decir que hoy
en día estemos exentos de vivir con este
problema vamos a poner un ejemplo y son
los países que restringen a los hombres
que han tenido contacto sexual con otros
hombres de donar sangre a pesar de que
hoy en día hay herramientas para hacer
pruebas antes de hacer transfusiones que
se sabe ya que nada tiene que ver con la
orientación sexual sino que tiene que
ver pues con conductas y con exposición
al riesgo y que eso le puede pasar a
todo el mundo a pesar de hay países que
donde todavía está prohibido donar
sangre si eres un hombre que yo bisexual
por ejemplo aquí en nuestra región
Venezuela pero también Turquía Grecia o
China y hay múltiples países Estos son
solo unos ejemplos que ponen
restricciones de tiempo entre 3-12 meses
algunos hasta cinco años desde el último
contacto sexual con un hombre para poder
donar sangre estamos hablando de países
como Estados Unidos o Canadá en el
continente americano pero es que también
Francia entonces vemos que hoy en día
todavía acarreamos esos pesos de la
discriminación que se vivió antes y que
se vive también como nos decían desde
Brasil en ese informe de valerías acone
hoy en día y seguimos en la actualidad y
le pregunto En qué situación estamos Sí
para para ir terminando vamos a hacer un
repaso de las cifras generales no
sabemos que hoy en día más de 38
millones de personas viven con el VIH en
el mundo 1.5 millones un millón y medio
de personas se contagian cada año es
decir hoy en día seguimos hablando de
unas dimensiones totalmente pandémicas Y
que además causa 650.000 muertes Aunque
podrían ser más podrían llegar hasta las
800.000 cada año también Pero además muy
importante un cuarto de las personas que
están contagiados de VIH no reciben
tratamientos precisamente estos
tratamientos que hoy en día existen
aunque no exista la cura existen muchos
tratamientos como las antirretrovirales
que ayudan a que esta enfermedad no se
contagie que ayuda a que no se transmite
que ayude también a vivir muchos más
años con esta enfermedad Como si fuera
una enfermedad Crónica que ya no es esa
sentencia de muerte sin embargo pues no
llega a todo el mundo y también por qué
Porque hoy en día las comunidades más
afectadas siguen siendo comunidades que
el mundo no quiere mirar por ejemplo
todas las personas que viven con esta
enfermedad en África subsahariana
también de nuevo comunidad lgbti o
trabajadores sexuales en a todo el mundo
en realidad entonces bueno siguen siendo
este problema y yo creo al menos Esa es
mi opinión que este hecho de que sean
estos Los afectados hace que sean mucho
más lenta la investigación y El Avance
Así es Mari Pues nada como siempre el
llamado a cuidarnos a la prevención
evidentemente usar en nuestros métodos
Pues que estén a nuestro alcance para
Exacto la información y pues a haceros
la prueba